hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to enter the gungeon
now I just couldn't stop playing it the
first one it is ridiculously awesome and
I need to show off a little bit of skill
here
Wow oh hey Wow god no I thought it was
dead I thought I was so dead oh man
so I'm playing with the mouse and
keyboard right now and holy crap pop
boink
okay this is gonna be this is this is
awfully powerful for one shot but I
don't know if I need this for this
oh god damn it thankfully it seems to be
a bit forgiving but how do I switch oh
oh there we go
oh my crossbow I've got a hunter's
crossbow or something like that oh
that's cool oh that's really cool okay
so this is my special thing that my
Hunter has hello stop that you stop that
right now
thank you you stop that nope I'm playing
with the mouse and keyboard now which is
actually way way easier than playing
with the controller because it was very
hard to aim with the controller sorry
it's alright whew sorry gotta play
better playing like crap
how about ski
god damn it will to reload on this guy
what are you doing ghost with a ghost
with a gun come out of nowhere
hey Baba whoop come on you wanna play
some more screw you buddy okay now if
only there was a way to like to clear
out the entirety of them do I have any
weapon oh maybe this can pierce boink
nope doesn't seem to be doing that ho
wow those guys would be asses come on
[ __ ] what are you doing with anything
when it keeps going with anything and
helping me okay that guy is that even a
Pucci is that a gerbil or something like
that it doesn't quite look like a dog
anymore
Mose looks like an overgrown rat hello
oh these guys mean business he's a super
oh-ho-ho
whoa whoa who did that who the hell who
the hell is blasting up a storm over the
wow these guys can take a lot of no no I
just started oh that's okay
someone shot me good the am Amana con ah
tits well that's the first death on my
accountants because I got too cocky this
time I'll do a lot better oh no I'm back
in chamber 1 ok I'm gonna blast through
this as fast as I can
I'm gonna get to chamber 2 where I mean
business give me I mean what about so I
got crossbow I'm gonna go with roof
sorry I for some reason I think space is
dodge but it's actually the right mouse
button and that's what throwing me off
at the moment yeah I'm gonna blame all
my problems on everything else whoo
that's grenade
hopefully I'll get something else other
than the railgun not that it wasn't
incredibly useful it's just it didn't
seem to help me a lot because of how
long it took to do that
hello oh I got a key okay maybe I won't
fast forward because I forgot that this
is all randomly generated yep sorry whoa
ha no you know how about no Oh nope this
doesn't seem to be doing a lot a little
piddly arrows here but maybe they can
pierce his armor eventually ah okay I'm
gonna go back to the sidearm hopefully
above like over time you can eventually
upgrade all of your [ __ ] oh you were a
ghost I didn't even know what you were
bullet the ghost of a bullet why do
bullets have ghosts I don't know why I
haven't questioned any of that before
but maybe because it's a video game this
makes any sense anyway so I can't go
that way just yet but I can't go this
way hello anybody here wanna die
horribly oh don't do that
there's a lot of you whoo whoo hey ho
hey ho hey ho hey ho okay
oh man that cover doesn't last very long
does it man there's so many of you ho ho
gotta show off some skill here it's not
all that difficult actually there's only
three of them and I thought I thought
there are more well that's not good
bah blah blah blah blah yay whoa CDs I'm
still getting an Rumble all right okay
just gonna change over here there you go
take some of this thank you
there we go they're dead okay so it's
it's it's awfully beneficial to switch
to something a bit more hard-hitting for
the big guys like my crossbow so I could
sing whoa hello that wasn't a letter
that was nothing here's pissed for no
reason buddy oh that is a four-leaf
clover what are you even doing with your
life where'd they go hello okay
are they gone okay I must have got him
go me go team go
okay holy [ __ ] do it I dare you pepper
oh okay whoa whoa okay Oh flank I don't
know how to use a blunt and no I do it's
Q here so I need to be more judicial
about my blanks well hello ooh what is
that ooh
Phoenix reborn in flame is it like a
flare gun or something
that's so cool what is cool Hey
whoa that's awesome I'd want to use that
on I use that on horror poor
unsuspecting creatures of the ow what
the hell where that Ghost come from damn
it
do that okay so it's super close range
but it does set them on fire I'll
goddamn it all the sudden I start
sucking as soon as I got a new gun nope
nope nope
surprisingly effective for the slimes
for damn sure okay good bye
hello nope oh why did you shoot first ah
damn it
why did he explode oh there was a barrel
by point sorry
by the way of world works oh whoa that
guy shot himself I guess they are
bullets so it makes sense yeah I kind of
don't like this gun cuz I gotta get so
close to him doggy can you help me out
here I really needed some help
apparently I'm doing very poorly who
another one hello whoa that's a lot of
stuff was this steady aim nice okay cool
for me even though I'm about to die
eventually but I can still carry on I
can do this
I'm not gonna die yet not without using
everything that I need
yes yeah I still like the gun better
just because it's it's super easy to
stay at a distance and out of being out
of distance is very important in this
game because you got to have room to
react when they're gonna shoot at you
another good thing about the game that
I'll say is that the music is phenomenal
like this is super cool music hello
like um I've noticed it's a trend lately
there's a lot of like pixelated style
games coming out one because it's easier
for developers to make instead of
focusing all the development on making
like superior artax art assets whereas
this one is different because it allows
for like much much much more refined
game mechanics and that's where this
game really shines
it's what the hell were you get out of
here what do you think you're doing Oh
what I lost a heart from shooting that
guy oh maybe I only bought one heart I
thought it gave me a full heart now
whatever the answer that question is
just don't get shot as much stop being
such a suck this Jack wants to tell me
I'm such a giant massive suck I don't
know how I end up getting it the boss
room at the very end hello you King
bullet how's it going I'm here to kill
you
Oh aren't you just delightful well time
to end your reign Oh your whole chairs
gone whoa okay whoop
oh there we go huh okay so what else are
you gonna do what else is new
whoa okay that's new whoa okay whoa geez
poor jeez Oh Gish hoagies
how is my Poochie getting out of this
okay I mean I'm happy about it but I'm
just wondering what his survival secrets
are whoa gasps oh yeah sure gasps whoop
oh god dammit why didn't roll that way I
was boring it upwards and like it like
it rolls in the direction that you're
moving not always in the direction that
you're just facing which would make my
life much easier this guy seems way
harder than the other guy I'm just gonna
say that right now
and try to put out the big guns on him
that's much more damage yeah that's
stupid revolvers like the pitiless
little tight wool little little
itty-bitty bits of damage see it's
always where you're going now where
you're aiming which I wish it wasn't Oh
getting cornered in corners what no not
in the VAD why would you do that why
would you do that and there we go you're
done baby I just blew up your chair your
phone oh he's very dead Oh God he blew
up in many ways not good all right what
do we got here what are you the people's
gun oh god it's just a better gun in
general hi
oh he's so sad too bad oh I didn't think
that I would actually do something I'm
so evil oh why did I kill him oh I
killed him so damned well people will
mourn another king another day I've got
a level 2 dungeon to go through and a
less suck to do that diantha couple this
game is so cool if you haven't played it
for yourself yet go play it it is
bonkers cool I just got to get better
used to the Dodge because I got I was I
was dodging up whoa what the whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa No thank you oh
wait what I don't like that
whoa hey whoa no snipers here excuse me
no the answer is no stop thank you thank
you for taking that guy out for me
good teamwork go team go okay those guys
suck
those guys ain't cool Oh what are you oh
god what is that why is there an iron
ball oh oh oh it's an enemy I didn't
know it was an enemy I thought it was
just an object okay oh my god that's so
that's so scary oh it's so scary yep
oh my it's like this guy's a little [ __ ]
god damn it oh oh my god damn it I just
used my burst I thought he was like a
boss I thought he was like a mini boss
are you gelatinous cubes oh I could have
overturned the tables I totally forgot
about that I keep forgetting to actually
use the environment in my favor I need
to be better about that hello buddy
thank you nope no no no no whoo this
game this gun isn't much different than
the revolver it's prolly about the same
damage as a revolver it's just um it's
just a bigger clip size which is good
question mark I guess I don't know I'm
gonna have to find out when I compared
later ooh hello thank you
what is you you can't a supe shot
Gazzola
oh cool nice what are you oh I have a
key I had a key
I'll goddamn it I had a key oh [ __ ] why
did I do that damn it not what I wanted
you look like you could help me you look
like interesting characters you look
like people that I should meet in this
adventure of mine you look so cool I
just want to be cool
what a cool little stumpy arm you have
on the left side okay bye then
if I find a key I'll come back to you I
found a key I thought I found a key in
this round but apparently not oh I'll
find something else some other day
no no no no no no thank you
oh that's unhelpful yeah maybe I can get
them to shoot each other
mappy possible nope nope really not whoa
okay then he just wanted to give up on
life
good to know wait was there something
else over there I thought I saw
something why oh no no no no where am i
fell damn it I fell again god damn it I
didn't see the pits ah don't do it don't
do it well that ends that one so oh no I
got shot I thought I fell I was gonna
fall anyway so it's fine okay so that's
all for this episode I promise I'll be
better in the next one I just panicked
in that room because I thought I was
gonna get assaulted by snipers and I was
and I got panicked into death so anyway
I'll pick this up again because this is
super cool but let me know what you
think of this in the comments below let
me know if you guys want to see more of
it because I am very eager to play more
of this so thanks again and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye
oh you're diggin Chuck we're really big
how do I respawn
oh god night wait a night okay I say go